[Music]  fourth-of-july right around the corner  people are gearing up for fireworks  barbecues but here's the problem  economy's in rough shape a lot of people  are on a tight budget so here was some  money saving 4th of July  tips once again is our prop master bill  tall no blue bag full of air pop it  boom firecracker here's bill with  another tip take a toilet brush light it  on fire  boom sparkler  [Applause]  here's bill with another tip take some  hot coals dump them down your pants boom  weenie roast  [Music]  another one  call your wife tell her it's over  boom Declaration of Independence take a  stripper's bikini put it on a stick  boom American flag  [Applause]  [Music]  finally a good tip from pill I can't  imagine that one saves money no I don't  know  [Laughter]